[Music]
six one seven nine seven eight five away
four one three the old mass
[Music]
see what i got
blanco cuatro
august 20th
spell life in the building
[Music]
i said look
my inner visions got no inhibitions i'm
down to die for all this [ __ ] but i
ain't finished living probably off the
coast of somewhere i'm just finished
swimming two pretty women flirting with
me it's a split decision look say my
great say my grace father cocaine off
the lord willing i go way farther
somebody told me to check the weather
but [ __ ] i ain't bothered cause every
time the sun shined it just rained
harder look i got a dope dealer's
appetite
still i never sacrificed my afterlife
keep all that gossip to yourself i ain't
the yappin type i rather cut you off the
first time before it happens twice
you know you gotta watch out for the
cobras the plug always told me i should
stash it by the folgers my heart turned
colder cause only sucker seeks sympathy
i'm sliding into tennessee who tends
with me symmetry this industry is faker
than the body and starlets i'm tired and
modest and i honestly think i am the
hottest cause ain't a rapper in his
business that's providing these projects
they give you high level rap and still
be highly melodic and i am the topic of
every barbershop in the region
crucifixes on my face but i have to walk
with the demons got these free codes
fiending in the telly to lick me i'm
entangled with older women trying to
date a and smith
hold up
let's see what else i got keep going
keep going
i got an infinity clip man
they say they love me when they see me
but i know it's hatred resent me from my
accolades and all the hoes i dated i
froze the braces they would rather be
golden plated living legend in boston
and i'm a golden cambridge know the
basics i just stick and move like a
prize fighter i'm just myself you play a
role like my car fighter i do this for
the single mothers trying to buy diapers
same old blanco but the rods nice to lit
like five lighters flow fire like butane
knocking wu-tang in the blue range
caught side of the garden so much they
thought i knew angel too much trauma in
my life i'm numb to new pain brown
maserati color poop saying i'm [ __ ]
on them vicious on them that's to drop a
bag blow 50 on them bust down glisten on
them
come on man what are we doing
and that's on the spot
i wasn't prepared
[Applause]
august 20th